[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
stop it you sexy people
happy America everyone it's Tuesday so
you know what that means
let's move together and we're in place
segment in television
[Music]
Tuesday on Saturday
welcome to trans Tuesday I'm your host
Angela Lansbury how dare you I did it
for you thank you tonight's topic jaws
drop after a top gets popped after
meeting with President Biden at a pride
event at the White House on Saturday a
transgender influencer bared her breasts
on the south lawn
bye Mr President it is an honor of fans
rights of Human Rights
[Music]
okay
are we topless at the White House
now I know what you might be thinking
what a bunch of boobs
seriously who invites these idiots come
on White House haven't you learned a
thing from Bud Light the only thing
influencers influence is universal hate
towards influencers
influencers are The credibility what
cancer is to your balls
I know also how the hell did we get here
where a person even thinks this is
appropriate at the White House even
Hunter said please a little decorum
[Music]
the fact is everything gone wrong these
days is based on not matching the
appropriate activity to the appropriate
venue I'd ask who's in charge over there
but Biden probably doesn't even know
when asked about Montoya burying her
chest Biden said I thought that was
Gerald Nadler leaving the Senate steam
room
oh we going to hell yeah that was mean
oh man now this is a fitting story uh
today because last week I got into a tip
with a friend of mine on trans issues he
claimed it's only an issue in the media
but everywhere everywhere else he says
it's nothing
and you know he's right we are putting a
hell of a lot of emphasis on something
that has little contact with the real
world we don't see this at all
so he says it doesn't matter but I say
it does because the last time I checked
the media reaches millions and has an
effect on how the world thinks and lots
of stuff I identify early on started out
as Fringe AI bail reform wokeness
fentanyl Taylor Swift
we pursued the lab League theories While
others just took a leak on it so is
trans an obsession or a delusion and how
can you assess it if the statistics suck
you can't even tell if they or them
refers to one person or a mob but that's
the point because we don't have the
stats and you shouldn't ask for them
because that says bad taste activists
talk about trans kids suicides like it's
rampant but does anyone ask for the
numbers do they improve after mutilation
and hormones or do they get worse
because plastic surgery and drugs aren't
the key to happiness just ask Mickey
Rourke
like all activists these demand
attention unrelated to their size and
they're effective because trans is
everywhere here's a sample from
yesterday's news
half of a British ladies fishing team
walks off after trans allowed to join
the most surprising thing about that
story was that there are female fishing
teams
of course the trans Fisher has an
advantage it takes a huge Rod to catch
something like that
oh the groans or just music to my ears
England's Health Service won't give
puberty blockers anymore to kids at
gender clinics you know too bad this
didn't happen before One Direction got
together
after a transgender cyclist named Austin
Phillips won a race in North Carolina
over the weekend beating out the closest
female racer by four minutes
tennis Legend Martina Navratilova
tweeted what a joke
and I agree with her and she once called
me an unfunny ass wipe
do you remember that oh yeah I remember
yeah I remember that
it's like the best moment of my life
point of Pride yes it is a point of
Pride now growing majority of the US is
against trans athletes competing outside
their birth gender and two-thirds say
they believe there were only two genders
34 disagree but they wouldn't know a
penis if you introduce them to Joe
Scarborough
now some stories are just plain dull
until you add that magic ingredient
trans for example a teacher's clothing
disrupts classrooms in Canada
here's the teacher
you see adult story becomes spectacular
thanks trance so it's my rule of thumb
on Gutfeld what the libs ignore or what
we gotta look at because what they
ignore reveals their delusion you know
like a penis on what they consider a
woman but it's not just trans the media
love talking about Criminal Justice
Reform until it became criminal party
time they called everyone racist until
there was no one left to call racists
they love drag and then it ended up at
kids libraries in every situation you
see a phenomenon take root and minus
limits a reason it always always goes
too far
for years we watched Illusions become
stories for political benefit Russian
collusion riots and looting is mostly
peaceful coveted spread by bats people
don't care about these things until they
have to and when it reaches the White
House I say they aren't given us much
choice
[Applause]
conditioner comedian and co-host of the
Jim Norton and Sam Roberts show Jim
Newark
nothing hurts like the truth and nobody
troops like the hurts Fox News
contributor election times opinion
editor Charlie hurt
she can be sarcastic in four different
languages Fox News contributor captive
and when they hand him a restaurant menu
he hands it back and says yes
my massive sidekick in the NWA World
Heavyweight Champion Tyrus foreign
whenever we cover this story we always
find out the ugly truth behind all of
them and you pinpointed it perfectly it
always involves not trans but an
influencer that's right influencers are
the root of all evil yeah they're
annoying so whatever they're
representing you find annoying because
it's an influencer yes doing it and I
don't see the I understand it's a little
tasteless to show your breasts at the
thought but it's funny the country just
hates each other like that's the big
like a lot of the people who are upset
about breasts at the White House had no
problem with the Q Anon Shaman in the
Capitol Building you know but chest yeah
he really did I mean great legs too but
I mean great rack make up your mind how
you feel about these institutions are
they sacred or is it okay to behave a
certain way in them that's a good point
I didn't look at it that way people were
just very upset uh that you know it was
again not appropriate but it wasn't like
she was you know swinging her penis in
the Rose Garden yeah it's true
unfortunately yes but see you know what
to be fair she was fondling Jim and and
I think you crossed the line when you
fondle you do it becomes terrific
the White House is boring and breasts
are great and every Tuesday in my life
is trans Tuesday so I was all for this
you don't even call it trans Tuesday no
it's Tuesday every day yes
I'd like to complain but hey it's right
in my face
Charlie what did you make of this uh
this uh incredible display of memories I
gotta say you make a good point I mean I
covered the White House at different
times that are under three
administrations and we never had this
story I will say we never had a the
South lawn was never turned into a strip
club uh which was uh probably a good
thing actually when I first saw the uh
the pictures I thought it was a
development in the story of Hunter's
laptop yeah and so I was like oh this
will be interesting
um but you know you raise obviously a
great point about you know whether and I
worry about this sometimes because we
talk so much about it whether or not
it's real or it's not but whether it's
manufactured or whether we talk about it
too much in the media at the end of the
day a lot of people aren't in on the
joke and you know just ask Riley Gaines
ask any of these women whose Sports have
been ruined by people who are you know
who don't think it's a joke and they
take it too far and they wreck people's
what people have spent their entire
lives devoted to perfecting and and it's
I did not know that I I didn't know that
there was a woman's fishing team an
example but I also didn't know that
there was a until you explained it right
there that there was a an inherent
advantage that men have over female I
guess it's like grip strength or
something like that well I just know
that anytime I've ever taken a woman
fishing she always out does me so it's
kind of humiliated the advantage a man
has is you can peel off the boat
this is true although I've seen well
never mind
do you know the white house uh later
condemned this incident uh so it's clear
it's this it's not allowed on the White
House lawn but is okay in our nation's
middle schools we'll be right back no
I'm kidding
I have some really fun tape this is the
influencer talking about why she did it
shall I play it for you and you can
respond please do all right
I had zero intention of trying to be
vulgar or be profane in any way I was
simply living in Joy Living my truth and
existing in my body
happy Pride free the nipple all right
cat I don't like anybody who ever says
living my truth well it's it's classic
influencer yes it is it is what they do
is they show off their bodies and they
include some you know inspirational word
salad reason for why they did so whether
it's this or it's like you know a girl
at like Machu Picchu holding her ass
cheeked up with her hands like a few
years ago I never imagined I would be
able to stand in my power like this and
it's like you want to show off your ass
because it looks good yeah she wants to
show off her boobs because they look
good so I I feel like I would have I
feel like people should just admit that
any influencer should just admit that
and also obviously most people who are
gay or who are trans they're not like
this they're just living their lives and
they're complex people who want people
to know things about them other than
their sexual or gender identity so this
is not representative of that but it
certainly is representative of an
influencer yes it is true Tyrus
well I think the good news is finally
somebody wants to go to the White House
[Laughter]
because it wasn't a long line to get in
there
it wasn't it wasn't a lot of dates
filled yes they can have it the the
downside is into to Kat's point
my issue is the it's the over
sexualization of everything and it just
sends a horrible message and and they're
influencing the wrong because for
example if I if I have a straight child
and a gay child in my household they're
the same rules my gay child is not going
to learn about sex any quicker or faster
than my Straight child is okay same
rules same dating habits no one allowed
upstairs no boys in the room no girls in
the room or whatever their deal is
when somebody who is not familiar
with the lifestyle doesn't know somebody
who's transgendered or knows somebody
who's gay or straight and this is what
they see on national TV every night it
influences them to think a certain way
right they think that all gay men act
this way all transgenders act this way
and it's shameful it's just like if
every time I came on this TV I robbed
you you know what I'm saying or always
had a piece right here what'd you say
cuz after a while people like wow man
brothers are horrible because that's all
they see but I don't carry myself that
way it might be fun to rob you yes but
but I'm not going to do it and the point
is because that's a stereotype they are
playing off the stereotypes and she got
the attention the apology is garbage but
and she would do it again
if you're going to go to the White House
you rep you're representing your group
if I was going to the White House I
would wear a suit even though you know
I'm the last guy to wear a suit but I'm
representing my family myself my name so
with all your pride try a little decorum
there you go well I think we covered
this intelligently and respectfully
boobs
way to bring it back thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else